[Music]
you posted a photo that made me think
and I think you tweeted this out that
you have a dangerous job this is where
you were at work the other day your
honor and that's a camera obviously
you're on a Ledge and it doesn't look
like there's anything stopping you from
falling we've filmed downtown all the
time and we're on all these building
types it's funny I always call my
buddies not be like you in the office
today and they're like yeah what's going
on I look out your window because we are
we are on we filmed everywhere in Los
Angeles um when the show is NCIS Los
Angeles it's the city is our character
so we are on the top of every building
in the city you know shooting guns and
helicopters and all sorts of stuff
that's the stuff that I would think
would just be a lot of fun when I was a
kid that would be my dream job is
running around firing a fake guy yeah
pretending to get shot falling down
that's you no no it is I mean we're
getting paid to play the games we've
played when we were kids I mean you know
we're in the desert
firing ak-47s the other day riding
horses and camels and all sorts of stuff
I mean it's it it's ridiculous why are
you riding camels in in in the Los
Angeles show I think the runners are the
writers are running out of ideas and
they're like a camel busted loose and
the boys have to catch it and aren't
these Navy crimes
we weren't actually riding the camels we
don't want it out ever you and the
camels are up to we don't want to know I
have a question for you do you still
have the Robin suit from the Batman and
Robin Dave I think we have we have a
picture here of the Robin suit it's a
very thin latex I mean that is it's very
thin but that was your real musculature
and you know what's so funny is I will
admit I was flexing my thigh for that
picture yeah I didn't not the upper body
but the thigh I was flexing why don't
they make men's clothing today that does
that I would buy that I want a suit that
looks like that what are you have 46
long what it what do you got I was like
I said these things I don't know what
its size I am I'm a zips up the back but
I would like to I would like to have
musculature built into my clothes and a
codpiece
not necessary
I would just I think that would sell I
think that's a great idea yeah I mean
you know I've heard stories of guys
wearing things that give them
musculature but yeah that's a little
strange
well that's what I'm into where do you
keep the Robin costume where is it
she has it next to the bed your wife now
I'm kidding
that's gonna say it's it she wants you
to put it on occasion now and then
Oh Robin rescue me what it is and she
likes it in the bedroom
no it's it's in like this giant wood
crate in the basement I been lugging
this thing around for 20 years I mean I
I when we did the movie I said I really
want to costume it yeah we'll send you
one and then this truck showed up with
this giant box and I've literally been
lugging it around for 20 years like what
we gonna do with it you're not gonna
like it bleh like hey guys have you seen
my Robin costume put it on and fight
crime
[Applause]